How's it going over there?
You're really ruining my flow
right now, you know that?
We got an issue.
There's movement, man.
We have 15 minutes.
It's time.
Hit it.
Hello, boys.
What if I told you...
I know what happens
when you die?
You become a ghost.
No more criminal records.
No more office parties.
Or stupid weddings.
Best part of being dead...
is the freedom.
Not policies or politics.
No one touch. He's mine.
We answer to no one.
We could take out
some truly evil people.
We're stuck at the stairwell.
Guys, I got a bad idea.
Don't have bad ideas.
Have good ideas.
Was that a bad guy?
These people
were declared dead.
None of us
will be remembered.
What's about to happen will.
Good things can erase
the bad ones, right?
Who the hell are you?
We're no one.
If they exist...
they could be made not to.
Papi, they have fighter jets!
-Are you seeing that?
-Yes!
Sorry for yelling.
Welcome to the world's
biggest magnet.
Are you out of your mind?
Grenade!
I wasn't sure it'd work.
I mean, I wasn't sure, sure.
I had a suspicion, but I...
God, this is all
so fucking dangerous.